As Charlie Kirk once said, you can tell
a lot about a person by how they react
when someone dies.
Well, the someone who died in this case
is Charlie Kirk. And some of the people
who are reacting are Sneo and his fans.
After news broke that Charlie Kirk had
been shot during a public debate at Utah
Valley University, Sneo posted, "Prayers
for Charlie Kirk and peace in America.
Guess how Sneo's Muslim fans reacted to
his call for prayers for Charlie Kirk
and peace in America. Make your
prediction.
Now, let's see if your predictions were
confirmed or disisconfirmed.
He's a despicable human being and a
direct enemy of our religion. Praying
for him is a sin. That doesn't mean we
should condone or cheer on this unjust
tragedy against him. And we can and
should pray for his family during this
time, but that's about it. Charlie Kirk
was an abominable man who despised
Muslims, despises our prophet, insults
our prophet, and endorses the slaughter
of Palestinians. He'll get no such
prayers from me or from any other
Muslim. I won't sit here fan the flames
of a volatile situation, but I won't
shed a tear for a man who grinned when
the blood of our brothers was spilt. To
be fair, as far as mocking Muhammad,
Muhammad was a child molesting,
murdering rapist, and the most obvious
false prophet in history. So, if anyone
in history deserves to be mocked, it's
Muhammad.
It is not proper for the prophet and the
believers to seek forgiveness for the
polytheists even if they were close
relatives after it has become clear to
the believers that they are bound for
the hellfire.
Quran 9113.
He insulted Islam and supported the
killings of innocent Palestinians. What
made you pray for him, brother? Yeah,
prayers for him to be put in deepest
depths of hell. He shouldn't have been
killed and vigilantism is wrong. But I
can't say I'm not happy. You donkey. He
supported the killing of Muslims as well
as insulted Allah and his messenger. Hey
Sneo, please don't be a prone. You are
our brother. But don't pray for a
non-believer because God prohibits that.
He rejected to believe in God. So
respect his choices and let him face
what he is facing now. Don't demand from
God to have mercy on the one who
rejected him. As Muslim, we shouldn't
pray for disbelievers.
I'm trying to pray for him. Rest in
hell, dear Charlie. Hey, Sneo, message
Shik Uman right now and ask him whether
praying for a kafir, Abu Jahal of our
time is kufur or not. Better time spent
than praying for someone on the same
camp as Netanyahu.
So this Muslim advises Sneo to contact
Shikman to ask him if he's allowed to
pray for someone like Charlie Kirk. But
this is just delusional. Anyone who
knows Shikman already knows that Shikman
is just going to say whatever Sneo wants
him to say because they're terrified of
saying something that will cause Sneo to
leave Islam. They don't want to lose
access to his fans. You want to make
some omelette, you got to break some
eggs. My thought exactly when I'm
mocking your fake prophet and you
complain that I'm hurting your feelings.
May Allah make me witness the horrors
that he will inflict on these filthy
enemies of Islam. Good riddance. May
Allah put you together with him on the
judgment day. My goodness. Now they want
Sneo to go to hell just for praying for
Charlie Kirk. He's looking up at us.
Amen. Please never claim to be a Muslim
again. What kind of hypocrisy is this?
Who's paying you? I hope he rests well
in hell. Praying he burns forever. Hope
he gets tortured. I'm praying for him
for a nice seat in Jahannim. Also, L
tweet brother do better. You're a
disgusting loser with no dignity. May he
burn in hell. 100 prayers that Charlie
Kirk goes to hell. Muslim praying for a
vocal enemy of Islam, a staunch advocate
of genocide against Muslims. Surah Atala
113. It is not proper for the prophet
and the believers to seek forgiveness
for the polytheists even if they were
close relatives. Pray for Charlie for
what? Burn well in hell. And the Warner
replies, "I pray that he burns in the
hellfire forever. He is an enemy of
Islam and an enemy Allah." That last one
probably hit Sneo hardest because the
Warner is Sneo's daab buddy. They go
around preaching Islam together. Even
though, as all these responses show,
Sneo still doesn't understand Islam at
all. Here are Sneo's thoughts on this.
after Charlie Kirk died.
>> You know what's so weird? Like I was
walking into the 911 museum and after we
went through security, Banks called me
and he's like, "Yo, check Twitter.
Charlie Kirk got shot." And like they
were playing the trumpets and all the
flags were there and people were like,
you know, doing a memorial for 9/11. It
felt like being at his funeral today.
What happened? Well, just now, I mean,
an hour ago, Trump announced that
Charlie Kirk passed away. And I just
want to start by saying rest in peace to
him and
although we have political differences
or we could disagree with people and
have conversations. I disagreed so much
with Charlie Kirk. Rest of soul.
>> I didn't agree with a lot of what he
said. Some of the stuff I I think was
good and valuable. But regardless, like
anybody who's celebrating his death is
in the wrong. You know, you you should
be able to disagree with people and have
conversations. So many pro Palestine
people saying that I shouldn't pray for
him because you disagreed with them.
What's wrong with you? You think God
wants you to celebrate his death? You
think God doesn't want you to pray for
his soul? Do you want me to to jump up
and down in joy because I disagreed with
him and and then he was shot in front of
a crowd? I I've seen it in in the love
speech community in a community called
love speech and I was hiding some of the
post myself. People saying you're
smoking on his pack celebrating his
death. This is a father. The world is
not going to be better off because
Charlie Kirk was assassinated. I can't I
to to see people it's we're not the
same. It's an evil evil mentality for
for and you're not going to convince me
otherwise. Any anybody saying that I
completely disavow
and I I don't want you to be a part of
of anything I do. When it comes to
having genuine concern even for people
he disagrees with on fundamental issues.
Sneo actually thinks like a Christian.
Jesus said in Matthew 5, or as Sneaker
would call it, Matt 5, you have heard
that it was said, "Love your neighbor
and hate your enemy. But I tell you,
love your enemies and pray for those who
persecute you, that you may be children
of your father in heaven." He causes his
son to rise on the evil and the good,
and sends rain on the righteous and the
unrighteous. If you love those who love
you, what reward will you get? Are not
even the tax collectors doing that? And
if you greet only your own people, what
are you doing more than others? Do not
even pagans do that? Be perfect,
therefore, as your heavenly father is
perfect. Jesus ordered his followers to
love their enemies and to pray for them.
Sneo obviously agrees, but Islam
doesn't, which is strange because all
the Muslims telling Sneo that he can
only wish death and destruction upon his
enemies are the same Muslims who tell us
that they respect Jesus. Guess what?
Sneo's Muslim fans have no more respect
for Jesus than they have for Charlie
Kirk.
I just wonder how much more obvious they
need to make it before Sneo finally
understands.
Prayers for Sneo and for peace in
America.
[Music]